[Music]
you never gone skinny-dipping I'm very
insecure we're going right now
but I think there's an acorn hiding your
pubes shut up I said skinny-dipping huh
mini dippin I should have just come
straight to New York to start my new job
come on man is your dad all right you
can handle this does he live down there
[Music]
hey Dad
any [ __ ] I didn't bring a bathing
suit problem solved three girls
chuckling yes hi
oh my god what's up guys that guy come
on we came tried to fight me what would
you do
that guy's a Marine I would take my
beating like a true American who would
you fight I totally [ __ ] your death
before this when my dad looks like a
human Muppet and I'm a hundred percent
sure he could kick your dad s what do
you think would win he's a lot bigger
than you he'd probably be sober which is
a huge plus
do you know how many fights I bin I
don't know six seven if you count that
little dust-up I had to use call my kids
lost all [ __ ] there's a storm brewing
on Maple Street I'm here to settle this
debate on kids that haven't weather
what's the debate we don't really care
about you guys fighting I think you do
you got five seconds to swing go I died
on 3 2 and that gazelle fleet
[Music]
where is that [ __ ]
how come you're not in New York my body
Sam my dad off a roof Joey yeah and then
they arrested US
you know with your one phone call last
night you called me and I lost my job
so you'll draw up the charges get me a
fool I'll drop the charges
how about a birdbath why I don't have
any [ __ ] Birds
I [ __ ] up his life pretty bad I got to
make it right I just got us a meeting it
is G we're getting you job back what are
you doing I'm gonna make this right for
you right no this is our V our meeting
space everybody
ah
some people say I'm unstable and I snap
that was a snap
[Music]